je vous le disais en titre la russie à
un nouveau premier ministre depuis ce
matin fidèle à son habitude boris
eltsine a surpris tout le monde en
limogeant sergueï stepachine qu'il avait
lui-même nommé il y a moins de trois
mois pour le remplacer il a fait appel à
un homme du sérail le chef des services
secrets vladimir poutine poutine que
boris eltsine a d'ores et déjà désigné
comme son dauphin prend les rênes au
moment où éclate la crise au daguestan
pierre didier filippis terre et jean
jacques botti
la dîmière poutine était chef du fsb les
services secrets héritiers du kgb il est
désormais le nouveau premier ministre
russe pressenti par le président et
mieux encore candidat désigné à la
succession de boris eltsine
dans une allocution télévisée le
président russe a clairement désigné
vladimir poutine comme son dauphin
engageant les russes à voter pour lui
lors des élections présidentielles de
l'été demi
limogé sans explication officielle le
premier ministre sortant stepachine lui
aussi ancien des services secrets a
réaffirmé sa fidélité à boris eltsine en
fait l'ancien et le nouveau premier
ministre se ressemblent beaucoup
nous sommes tous deux s'étaient pas
chine et moi des militaires donc nous
exécutons un ordre qui nous viennent de
l'autorité suka
la classe politique russe condamne le
nouveau changement de premier ministre
les élections législatives auront lieu
dans cinq mois le parti communiste
dénonce la stabilité gouvernementale
c'est à 100% une maison de fous en 18
mois nous avons eu six premiers
ministres le dernier gouvernement a tenu
82 jours pour nous rien n'a changé c'est
l'agonie d'un régime
que récemment donc un rapport mettant en
cause
probablement l'entourage de la famille
helsinn dans le détournement des fonds
qu'elles étaient octroyés par le fmi en
juillet 1998 alors ces machines avaient
échoué à étouffer cette affaire est
certainement une des tâches qui sera
signé au premier mini c'est d'étouffer
cette affaire vladimir poutine à d'ores
et déjà annoncé qu'il y aurait peu de
changement dans la politique économique
la bourse de moscou a pourtant perdu 11%
ce matin à l'ouverture et le rouble est
en baisse malgré les interventions de la
banque centrale